are we alone in the universe chris mason
what do you think so yeah the
presumption that you've just mentioned
is let's just focus on our thing yeah
for now
well i i think we
as far as we know with no other sentient
life on the universe that we've found
yet
and and i think there's probably
bacterial life out there just because we
found it everywhere we've looked on
earth it is
and there's you know halophilic
organisms that can survive in extreme
salts there are
psychophiles that it's extreme cold
there's you know basically organisms can
survive in really almost any possible
environment they can adapt and find a
way to live
but as far as we know we're the only
sentient ones and i think
this is the famous the drake equation or
you know how many
where is everyone is that what enrico
fermi said is the
why haven't we heard from anyone there
are these other life forms i actually
think the question is wrong
to phrase it that way because the unit
the earth has only been here for 4.5
billion years
and we and you know life may be only for
a few billion of those years complex
life only for several hundred years 100
million years of life we've actually had
you know in humans only the past few
million years since our last common
ancestor so it's not that much time
but if you think even further back the
universe hasn't had that much time
itself to cool and create atoms and have
them spread around the the universe
right so the current estimates 13.8
billion years of just the whole universe
but it spent the first five or six of
those billion years really just like
cooling and making enough of the
stars to then make the atoms that would
come from supernovas so i actually think
we might be the first or still one of
the very few or one of the early life
forms but the universe itself hasn't had
that much time to make life any integral
in a galactic and universal time frame
you needed billions of years for the
elements to be created and then
distributed and we're only really in the
i think the last few billion years where
i think even life could have been made
so i think the question of wherever is
everyone is the wrong question i think
the question is
i think we are the first ones at the
party
let's set up the liquor let's set up the
food we i just think we're the first
ones at the party of life but more
people are coming
one of the early attendees to the party
yeah or maybe the for as far as we know
the first but maybe in the local pocket
of the universe
um because the parties then expand and
you it overflows yeah
and then there's a mosh pit and then you
know bump into the other galaxy uh i
think it's i think the question should
be
we know when else is everyone getting
here instead of where is everyone i
think i think we've just started on the
genesis of life in the universe
yeah so not not worry have they or not
more
about when and who
and how do we set up the party right and
then how do we help them i think it's an
interesting other moral question is do
we you know the a lot of star trek
episodes the prime directive is you do
not interfere with another planet if you
could pass by a planet i think it's time
to also revisit that because what if
what if you go by a planet and we think
that with as far as we can tell with
enough certainty that they would never
be able to leave their planet and then
the sun eventually would engulf that
planet wherever that planet might be in
some solar system
but if we had a way to help them their
culture their science their technology
everything about a different species to
survive
would we not interview interfere i think
that would actually be wrong to say well
we can save this this life here and we
decide not to we decide
after bill millions and billions of
years past and we know the sign will
engulf that planet like what will happen
with our planet and we don't interfere
that's you know watching a train hit
someone on the tracks and not moving the
train